hi my name is now I'm from Wolfram
research and i'll be talking about how
to make a demonstration for the Wolfram
demonstrations website thanks Anthony um
I as he said I'll be talking you through
how to write a Wolfram demonstration
this will be quite an introductory thing
so going from how to build your code
initially to filling out the template
and then submitting it so the first part
of this what is a demonstration done the
demonstrations project is was launched
by Stephen Wolfram as a way of
distributing people's interactive code
to other people so your what we're going
to try to do here is walk through
creating an interactive application so
an interactive visualization of some
concept and then putting it online so
that people can view it embed it in
their websites and play with the code
the demonstrations project is available
at demonstrations Wolfram com there's
lots of great stuff on that the things
that you need first of all you're going
to want an idea so hopefully you've got
lots of ideas from this conference
they've been some fascinating talks so
try and think of something some code
next to fill it out so using the
manipulates function then you're going
to want a demonstration template to fill
out and finally once this is submitted
it will be using the computable document
formats and the CDF player so that other
people can view it and interact with it
first of all an idea what should you
write for a demonstration well you can
write anything everybody here has some
specialty some things that you're
interested in if you go on to the topics
page of the manipulate website you can
see we've got this big range of areas so
you could go to anything say music for
example if you look through here you can
search by keyword so something that you
might want to write about for example
making a keyboard well some other people
have done it but there's obviously some
room for you to write something if
somebody's already done the
demonstration
you'd like to write then just try and
frame it in a different way display
slightly different aspects explain it
differently if you still need more
inspiration there's obviously all the
examples existing so we've got
architecture fitting some silly games
like sheep descender entirely not Tetris
robots population modeling it doesn't
have to be a visualization so we have
solving differential equations with
different methods it can just be a
text-based thing so on to the meat of it
the manipulate manipulate is what you
need to use to create this demonstration
everything has to be using the
manipulate function that's what
everything is framed with its most used
for creating applications like this this
is a much more complicated one so we can
have lots of different controls and some
dynamic visualization or output this is
a really complex example you can do
simple things as well like the most
basic a slider changing X this is the
fundamental of a manipulate the syntax
is manipulate than the expression that
you're varying and your variable over
some range there are also different
forms for it so using information we can
look at all the different ways of
writing it you've seen here so
expression you you minimum and you
maximum you can add step sizes or extra
variables or discrete values they're all
all of these are documented fully so
there are examples in the documentation
so the expression that you very it could
be anything in this case it's a plot and
we're just plotting a basic sine and
we're going to change some variable in
there in this case B and you can add
multiple controllers so to make the more
complex interactive applications you
just need to add more variables so here
we're generating some initial values for
a fit so if you try and fit some
function it's fairly easy to do you just
lift your ranges
so because it's just an expression
either a visualization or some text you
can insert anything in here so say
mathematics you can expand out some
polynomial or you could manipulate an
image sometimes you have to be a little
careful when you manipulate some large
graphics because it does have to be
redrawn every time you change your
variable so it can get quite slow you
can also vary a program so if you want
to interactively generate a program and
see what changes how that varies the
outputs so here we could have some
function that we'd then use elsewhere
you can get quite complicated with that
it gets fun and also 3d graphics again
depending on what your 3d graphic is and
how complex the rendering functions it
can get slow but generally it's pretty
quick manipulates very clever over
deciding which options you need so you
have some content you now need to have
different controls so a slider isn't
always appropriate we have lots of
different control types this being the
numerical slider that will usually be
automatically chosen for anything which
is X from a number to another number if
you give a list so discrete values you
can generate drop-down menu so this is
doing range 20 you can also have two
dimensional inputs so we have slider TD
say you want to change some vector or
something you can easily move that
around sometimes that's a lot more
appropriate than a slider would be we
can also have text inputs so just an
input fields this can be useful for
creating forms or some kind of survey
for example so we can just enter that
and it automatically updates
you just click outside the input field
so once you finish typing for example
sign I then move my mouse outside and
click if you want to manually change it
you can use the control type option so
this is moving away from the defaults
because sometimes you don't necessarily
want to drop down menu so here we have a
set a bar or you could have some
drop-down there's a large number of
control types here are just a few
examples of them so you've seen some
sliders already we have vertical and
horizontal different setters and so in
some kind of view you can also have tab
views if you want to have a pain where
you tab through different parts of your
expression different drop down menus a
nice feature of this drop-down is that
you can have the expression that you're
changing it to shown in the drop down
menu master control is nice for if
you're trying to have people directly
interact instead of having some other
external controller so you can just have
clips in here there's this gauge where
you can just interact with it we also
have fun special selectors so things
like a file name you can have your
document browser automatically open up
or color sup color setters this is a
color set above or animators if you
won't say a rotating globe for example
you can animate things automatically
which one this one oh here this is I
can't remember the name of that I think
it's multi set up in just double check
so that is forgotten there a list pecker
that's what it's called
so moving on to some more advanced
functionality you have your code that
would be whatever you develop but
there's also other ways of changing how
manipulate behaves localization is
usually very important when you're
interacting and dynamically varying lots
of different things nipply automatically
localizes any control variables so in
this manipulates if we vary X here it
wouldn't change outside you can turn it
off if you want your manipulate
interacting with other applications so
say you want to vary it somewhere and
then else are in the notebook you want
the same settings you can just use
localized variables goes to false so now
we can interact you can also initialize
code so often you need to initialize
some other expressions to have it either
run more quickly or have certain things
functioning the way that they're meant
to this is just using initialization
goes to whatever expression you just
provide a list of different
initializations it can speed things up
quite a lot and speaking of speed
there's a lot of detailed control about
different rendering speeds so as I said
before using images sometimes it takes a
long time for it to update all with 3d
graphics so in this case we have our
plot 3d plot 3d takes quite a lot of
work so you can see the automatic
behavior is to turn down the quality
loads so while I'm moving this slider it
looks pretty rubbish when I let go it
goes to the full full detail so it has a
proper output view you can just stop
this dynamic updating if you decide that
actually it's not really relevant that
they can see it moving around you use
continuous action ghost of false and
then while the slide is being moved
nothing happens and when released you
get the full detail you can also use
performance goal if you want to specify
whether you want accuracy whether you
want speed what's more important
sometimes a laggy controller is fine as
long as you get all the detail while
it's moving so here you can see my mouse
is quite delayed
moving slidable we get our full quality
all the way through if you want even
more control over it there's the control
active option here so this is a direct
ratio between active and inactive
controls so here we have control active
it's a third of the quality while I'm
moving that controller so this is much
nicer than the original default behavior
and finally appearance so with the
parents you often want to make your
application look good you are generating
a graphical interface for a reason you
want people to see it properly so here
we have our default behavior where the
sliders are at the top we can label them
just by using appearance goes to the
labeled alternatively giving an extra
option of what the label for that
control is so here we're saying W from
one to ten initial value of one and
label of frequency and you can move your
controls around using control placing
goes to left right top bottom you can
specify quite detailed positioning there
are also a delimiter object object so
these are treated just like graphics
constructs it's a separator so that you
can have different groups of controls so
here we have our horizontal and vertical
controllers separately and finally you
can add a pain on the outside so if you
want to have a completely customized
area you add a pain around the outside
and set its various options so here we
have this is just our manipulate code
with all the delimiter zand different
styles way through here and we have all
our safe definition set to true so
everything will automatically load with
our notebook and there's this paint
framed around the outside meaning that
it creates a pain and we can set up base
styles for all the fonts so you have
everything be consistence we can say the
background goes to black and you end up
with a much nicer looking area so here
we just have some window editing thing
so you've got your code you've generated
manipulate made it look good now you
need to turn it into a demonstration
this is just with in Mathematica you go
to file new and demonstration it's that
easy once you've done that you end up
with a template if I show you that so
you have a template with various areas
to be filled out whenever it appears no
okay
going to leave that because my
computer's being fussy today so you end
up with various different areas to fill
out so tight or manipulate caption these
are all the mandatory fields so you have
to fill those out for us to have the
information that we need you can also
add extra things so control suggestions
so you can help people to interact with
your demonstration fully there is a full
page of author guidelines if you want to
have a look in more detail later that
just talks you through everything that
you need to do so to start with the
title and your initialization this is
the first part you need to name your
demonstration if you try and give it
something quite descriptive so in depth
names but without too many words people
don't want to read a paragraph about
what you're doing just in the title so
give it a brief name usually giving it
keywords that people will immediately
recognize so they understand what's
happening and then initialization so set
up your code ready you just drop in the
initialization code into this area it's
completely optional but it can be useful
for you to include it explicitly and
then putting in your manipulate code in
the template we just have this
description and a template manipulates
you just put all your code in the place
of that cell and after that we have a
caption so your caption is one or two
sentences just describe what's happening
what's your manipulate intended to do
what's the output the thumbnails
thumbnails are copied and pasted
manipulates at a certain setting so you
won't have a thumbnail so people can see
a small image of what's going to happen
you don't put an image in here that's
what happens later on in the CDF you
just replace it with the manipulate
itself copied and pasted the same with
the snapshots just put a few examples of
interesting ways of using your
manipulate copy and paste them in more
optional details we have an in-depth
detail
section so here you can put in your
references to say you used a certain
book or somebody else's input you'd
reference them here and put a bit more
detailed so here there's just a brief
example of hypercube manipulation so
talking about the math behind it and
what's actually happening still don't
try and make it a full paper on it just
an abstract is good and control
suggestions so sometimes it's not very
clear how you can interact with
something so you junk you can't tell
that it's actually locator pain so you
just show people that you can click and
drag or resize things to get new
interesting interactions authoring and
references tell people who you are we
want to know who wrote this so we can
say you wrote something fascinating
everybody wants to go and ask you about
it tell people if you have other wolfram
pages so documentation that you think
might be informative to people link it
here so this is just for Wolfram
references you'd put in the detail
section any external references and
finally upload it you just submit it to
the demonstrations page there's an
upload area so you can become a
demonstration submitter you do just
enter your email address and password
and drop it in this is a link directly
from the template and finally once
you've done that it will appear on our
demonstrations website using the cdf so
computable document formats people can
interact with it in their browser using
the cdf plug-in or embedding people can
then go and take it and put it on my
website using this the cdf technology so
you know all of the code will be freely
available to people so if you have
anything highly confidential I wouldn't
recommend making it a demonstration
people can then go and use it for their
own personal educational just advancing
their code and that's it for me